thank goodness it's Friday April
eighteenth and you're watching gamespot
news I'm Chris waters here to kick off
your weekend with a look back at the
week's top five stories which quote
announcement reveal happening or
celebrity selfie we'll take the number
one slot let's find out PAX East
concluded in Boston earlier this week
spawning two great gamespot panels a
bunch of pox-ridden gamers and some new
footage of diablo 3 running on the
PlayStation 4 a video posted to gamespot
shows the game running in 1080p at 60
frames per second with commentary from
the developers illuminating many of the
new systems that will ship with the
so-called ultimate evil edition there's
no ps4 release date announced as of yet
but that's a better fate than the xbox
one version which may never even launch
depending on how things shake out
between blizzard and microsoft sony is
saying sayonara to its stake and Square
Enix unloading 9.52 million shares in a
transaction worth about 47 million
dollars it's tempting to view this as a
rebuke to the recent incarnations of
Final Fantasy especially if you played
lightning returns but sony has been
making cost-cutting moves for about a
year now having announced that it will
sell to major office buildings lay off
thousands of employees and even sell its
pc division as a means to return to
profitability no word yet on how that
secret chocobo breeding program will be
affected by this deal the release of
watch dogs is just over a month away
barring any further delays and the
creative director recently shared the pc
specs you'll need to be a phone obsessed
vigilante on ultra settings if you've
got an intel core i7 4770k with a g4 780
you're good to go if not then you might
want to take a look at the minimum and
recommended system requirements as
posted on gamespot the requirements
don't specifically mention wearing an
actual baseball cap in trench coat while
you play the game but after seeing Danny
O'Dwyer dressed up in the latest episode
of the point you might want to
reconsider
though it's in the number two slot this
next story is number one in my heart
because I love civilization and there's
going to be more civilization and it's
going to be in space sid meier's
civilization beyond earth is the
spiritual successor to Alpha Centauri
and once again players will leave Earth
to colonize a new planet alien life will
offer new challenges and new resources
while the tech web will allow nonlinear
technological advancement there's a ton
more details in our week-long coverage
of the announcement so be sure to check
it out and tell me which one of the new
wind conditions appeals to you most my
personal choice is harmony in which you
awaken a semi-sentient super organism
within the planet and reach a new level
of consciousness gosh the biggest news
of the week broke yesterday as the NPD
announced that for the third month in a
row the PlayStation 4 has outsold the
Xbox one even with titanfall topping the
charts as the best-selling game the Xbox
one is still significantly behind the
ps4 consider this the ps4 has sold seven
million units through to customers
whereas the Xbox one has told only five
million units through two retailers
meaning they're still counting systems
that are sitting on store shelves that's
not great for Microsoft as they were
probably hoping for a boost from their
big exclusive but system wars are good
for the industry as a whole which is up
three percent over last year at this
time thanks largely to the brisk
hardware sales and that's it now you can
head into your weekend armed with all
sorts of scintillating conversational
bits that I can't guarantee anyone else
is going to find interesting but you did
and that's why we love you thanks for
watching folks have a great weekend
you